mirador al tronco tiene en este momento
al partido republicano en una situación
donde es un callejón sin salida y
posiblemente se lleve a una ruptura
total una guerra civil dentro del
partido porque te digo esto porque los
fanáticos del trono las personas que
apoyan a trong lo apoyan en una forma
decisiva a una casi de práctica y eso es
lo que van a votar en las primarias en
las primarias para el congreso y para el
senado dentro de dos años estas personas
van a decidir quiénes van a ser los
candidatos republicanos y por eso es el
miedo de los senadores en este momento
de los senadores republicanos en votar
en contra de toronto en este juicio
político el impeachment porque saben que
si votan en contra de tron los
simpatizantes dentro no van a salir en
masa en la primaria para votar en contra
de ellos
ahora qué pasa trump tiene una minoría
de un 30 a un 40 por ciento del pueblo
americano así que si las y los
candidatos que apoyan a trump son los
que ganan las primarias republicanas
esos candidatos van a perder cuando
lleguen el momento de la elección
general así que es una es una situación
donde el partido se encuentra en una muy
muy difícil situación si ganan las
primarias nuestros pistas saben que son
candidatos que van a perder la elección
general en las próximas elecciones